so I'm not sure why people use this
expression that the chemistry is right I
think it's because in chemistry
different atoms and different compounds
combine together to form really stable
molecules or complexes so just in the
same way if you get the right two people
they will react together and give a very
stable combination some of the others
may give something that's a bit more
volatile or occasionally a pairing
that's even explosive but that's what
makes chemistry fun and it's what makes
relations fun as well
come in happy Valentine's Day from a
chemist point of view one of the most
interesting things about chocolate is
its melting point chemically mixtures
often have rather ill-defined melting
points they don't melt all at once but
with chocolate it's different and it has
a very sharp melting point so the
chocolate in your hand doesn't melt but
as soon as it gives in your mouth which
is only a little bit warmer than your
hand it melts and it melts very sharply
to give us rather smooth solid smooth
liquid which gives you this very sensual
flavor in your mouth another big part of
Valentine's Day are roses and flowers in
general but particularly roses and
particularly red roses the smell
molecules are really or fragrance I
should say it's a polite a word for a
nice smell ah really quite simple
molecules so that when people are
collecting the fragrance from roses to
make perfume for example they have to
collect the Roses early in the morning
before the Sun has heated them up and
all the smell has evaporated my favorite
piece of chemistry comes with these
mints which have chocolate on the
outside but if you break them you can
see inside they're all soft and gooey so
think for a moment how is it possible to
put such a nice layer of chocolate over
something that is so gooey and liquid
and it's done with a very neat chemical
trick because the inside of these
chocolates when they're made and coated
is made out of sugar now when this is
mixed up you can make really quite a
stiff paste it's essentially a solid but
it is mixed with a naturally occurring
enzyme called invertase
and when the chocolate coating has been
put on and it's already put into the box
a chemical reaction starts between the
invertase and the sugar the molecules of
sugar
consists of two rings joined together by
an oxygen atom in the middle and the
info T's splits these two rings apart to
make two other sugars fructose and
glucose and when these are mixed
together they give you this sort of
liquid and the longer you keep the
Mint's the more and more liquid it gets
so I'm not a specialist in the colors of
roses but you can see that you can get
red ones and you can get all sorts of
different colored roses which have been
bred to give these different colors now
as a chemist I know that these colors
are all viewed to organic compounds
these acount compounds of carbon which
might have a little oxygen and nitrogen
as well but the color is usually
associated with a string of double bonds
between the two carbon atoms carbon
atoms can be linked usually a linked
with just a single bond between two
atoms but sometimes you can have a
double bond and occasionally you can
even have a triple bond but a line of
these double bonds will give rise to
color and the longer the line of the
double bonds or the chain of double
bonds in general the more the color
shifts towards the red different
molecules will have different colors now
it's my personal feeling and this is
just a guess but I think it's very
unlikely that people breeding roses can
suddenly persuade a rose to produce a
completely different compound so it's
much more likely that the rose color is
due to a mixture of several compounds
each of which has a slightly different
color if you stop the rose producing any
compounds it will be white but if you
alter the proportion then I think that
you can get these different colors like
orange or yellow or deep red
so a selective breeding will allow you
to vary the proportions but none of
these compounds is blue which is why
without genetic engineering or something
more clever you can't make a deep blue
rose because the colors are just not in
the palette chocolate contains a
compound called theobromine which is
very similar to caffeine the difference
in structure between caffeine and
theobromine is just the position of one
group with containing carbon and 3
hydrogen's so chemically they're quite
similar and so that the effect of
theobromine is also to heighten the
effect of eating the chocolates but
theobromine is a stimulant and it is
forbidden for racehorses so if you feed
a chocolate bar to your racehorse if
you're rich enough to have one then if
the horse wins the race it may be
disqualified because they can detect
theobromine in the horse's urine when
they do a drug test
roses are quite amusing for chemists
because you can do quite a nice trick
with them now if I dunk the rose into
liquid nitrogen which is at minus 196
degrees centigrade nearly minus 200
degrees centigrade the nitrogen starts
boiling and the cold gas comes out and
nitrogen is completely colorless
Pritikin dead the coal gas condensed
water vapors so you see what looks like
like smoke so if we take it out now it's
gone quite brittle so if I just bang it
it now breaks into little pieces
because the water and the petals have
frozen